hey everyone its Johanna here it's the
holiday season and perhaps you can't
help yourself but to over indulge in the
holiday feasts chances are you might be
feeling tired and bloated due to the
excess amount of sugar refined carbs
salt and alcohol consumption excess
amount of refined sugar causes spikes in
our blood sugar level which means more
cravings for sugary food excess amount
of salt causes puffiness and water
retention and excess amount of alcohol
causes dehydration so it is important
for us to cleanse our body from all the
toxins that has been built up over the
past week from holiday abuse we will not
be doing any extreme detox for instance
going on a liquid diet for the next
three days because it is not needed in
States we want to be eating light and
clean for the next two to three days to
release water retention and bloatedness
to rebalance our blood sugar level and
to recharge our energy and metabolism
this detox plan will be based on cutting
our starchy carbs in order for our body
to flush out all the unneeded water
rapidly we will be consuming a lot more
plant-based food which is high in fiber
protein and healthy fats so let's put
all our holiday indulgence aside and
let's go on to this detox plan for the
next two to three days to cleanse our
body or mind and our soul so let's start
with our drinks for the next two to
three days I want you to only be
drinking either water green tea or apple
cider vinegar before you have your
breakfast start your morning by drinking
half a liter of water and throughout the
day you can either drink one of these
drinks or combined then green tea and
apple cider vinegar helps to ease
digestion and help to remove toxins from
our body at a faster rate so drink at
least
into ten cups a day as for our breakfast
we want a high-fiber breakfast what I
have here is oatmeal peanut butter to
make this cook 40 grams of oatmeal with
100 ml of water and 100 ml of milk once
it's cooked makes the peanut butter in
if you know you're lactose intolerance
drinking milk can cause bloatedness and
discomfort so up for soya
almond or rice based milk I'll just cook
your oatmeal with water
oatmeal is very high in fiber and it's a
natural diuretic which helps to release
excess water in our body peanut butter
is your healthy fats and it promotes
healthy digestion as for your lunch we
want to keep it light by having soup
base meal what I have here is chick peas
carrots and onion soup it is really
simple to make so the ingredients you'll
need are 200 gram of carrots chopped
into cubes 1 whole onions diced 2 cups
of chicken or vegetable stocks half a
can of chickpeas washed and drained 1
TSP of olive oil and a handful of fresh
or frozen parsley the first step is to
heat olive oil over medium-high heat
then add the onions and carrots and
lightly stir fried until the onions are
lightly Brown and fragrant add your
chicken or vegetable stock and bring to
a boil allow the carrots to cook for 15
to 20 minutes until very tender don't
forget to stir occasionally then remove
the pot from the heat and puree the
carrots either with a hand blender or a
food blender until smooth
bring the pot back to a boil under low
heat add the chickpeas and parsley
allowed all the ingredients to simmer
for another 5 minutes and serve you're
getting the vegetables and fiber from
the carrots protein from the chickpeas
and healthy fat from the olive oil
having soup for your lunch will make it
easy for your body to digest
and it will allow your stomach to have a
break from the holiday abuse as for
dinner we want to pack on more fiber and
also to pack on lean protein what I have
here is a salmon red cabbage salad the
ingredients you will need are two cups
or 150 gram of red cabbage shredded
three ounces of seven or chicken breasts
if you are a vegan choose tofu or beans
two teaspoons of olive oil and half a
tablespoons of mixed seeds all I've done
is to toss the red cabbage with mix
seeds and olive oil and to top it up
with the baked salmon you're getting
your fiber from the red cabbage which
helps to promote healthy bowel movements
healthy fats from the mixed seeds olive
oil and omega-3 from this salmon and of
course protein as well if you prefer to
cook your red cabbage you can lightly
stir fry it with olive oil so this is
your protein pack dinner as for your
snack what I have here is a large green
smoothie we want to pack a lot more
green vegetables into our diet to
rebalance our blood sugar level and to
get rid of all the toxins to make a
green smoothie it is really simple just
think of having these four ingredients
first choose your green vegetable you
can use one or more for instance kale
bok choy broccoli cabbage spinach
zucchini or sprouts what I have in here
is spinach second choose your liquid
again you can use one or more either
water soy milk almond milk or even
coconut milk what I have in here is a
combination of soil and water third
choose your fruit or vegetable again you
can add one or more for instance tomato
carrots apple pumpkin banana or berries
and what I have in here is banana and
finally number four your add-ons for
instance protein powder cinnamon or goji
berries or even flax milk what I have in
our goji berries to make my green
smoothie I have used 150 gram of frozen
spinach 150 gram of frozen bananas 100
ml of sir milk 100 ml of water and 1
tablespoon of goji berries and I have a
huge and really delicious green smoothie
so have this for your snack so do try my
3 day detox plant to rebalance your body
mind and soul to Kate start the new year
fresh you can also use this detox plan
for 1 or 2 days if ever you find
yourself over indulging on certain
occasions but this should not be your
reason to constantly over eat and then
detox to the next day be kind to your
body there is no reason why we should
not be able to enjoy our holiday parties
without overthinking it is Christmas so
Merry Christmas I hope you are having a
lovely time
and have a great new year ahead for new
Fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
You Tube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
to stay connected with me thanks guys
you